to take curcumin but it really bothered myself, is that a genetic problem? No, there's
only not too by knowledge that there is any genetic issue with curcumin. So a person
isn't genetically sensitive to curcumin, but curcumin is a food and a person can develop
antibodies to curcumin. So you can develop antibodies to anything. So if you develop antibodies
to curcumin, then every time you take curcumin, you're creating an inflammatory reaction.
So if you have antibodies to curcumin, IgA or IgG antibodies to curcumin, every time
you eat it, within 0 to 20 hours, you're going to have an inflammatory response. So depending
on how high your antibody level is to curcumin, this would be true if you had antibodies to
gluten or dairy or asparagus or any other food. If you have antibodies to a food and you consume
that food, you're creating this inflammatory response, basically a fire in the gut in the
body and you could have systemic inflammation. So people will make a comment like, I can't
take curcumin because it just bothers me so much. They probably have antibodies to it. Now,
I will say that the antibodies to many foods will dissipate over time. So let's say I used to
take curcumin 10 years ago, but it really bothered my stomach. So I stopped taking it. By all means,
you could try taking it again because usually if you stay away from a food and gluten is the
only exception, due to the dairy really are there are two main exceptions for that. But if you
stayed away from a food that you have antibodies against, many times those antibodies will dissipate
over the course of three to six to nine months. You really stay away from curcumin. You may not
have any antibodies to that anymore and you could safely take it. Well, will I cause another reaction
on the metabolic antibodies again? No, not at all. The reason why you would erodeously develop antibodies
to a food is that if you have permeability in the gut or another reason for inflammation of the
gut, but got permeability aka leaky gut will open the barrier so that you will absorb things that you
shouldn't have absorbed and then you would cause an immune reaction to that thing that should never
be as a bloodstream and that you create antibodies against it. That's the reason why you create antibodies
to food is because of a leaky gut. So you've got permeability for whatever reason, you know, you
caused inflammation of the gut, maybe parasites, maybe toxins that you're exposed to, whatever,
now you have damaged gut, probably the most common reason is antibiotics and other medications that
cause inflammation of the gut causes gut permeability issues and then you could develop antibodies to
good foods like curcumin would be a good food and now you have antibodies against that and you can't
eat it for a period of time. So just because you reacted to it 10 years ago doesn't mean you'll
react to it today so I would just go slow and take caution and make every observation.